hey everybody it's Mike from orderflows
and in today's video I'm going to talk
about the concept of trap Traders CU
it's an important one in orderflow
analysis and uh before I jump in again
if you haven't already be sure to
subscribe to the channel and uh hit the
like button if you'll enjoy this video
and be sure to leave a comment down
below I do go through the comments and
uh sometimes I do make videos based off
of them
so trap Traders okay it refers to
traders who have entered positions at
unfavorable price levels and are
essentially trapped in losing positions
and sometimes you could see them at
reversal points okay and you know this
is a bonds a four range chart I like
looking at Bonds on a four range chart
and just looking at this move here right
let me get the crosshairs up here you
know we had this nice little swing High
here this little double top um at
11625 and then we sold off down to you
know down to 03 okay so you know a move
from basically 20 down to 5 in the bonds
that's a nice move um you know today was
CPI day and you know I'm not even going
to talk about that big move here uh
lower cuz you know you're not going to
be trading when the CPI comes out but
when analyzing order flow trap Traders
can be identified by significant
imbalances or excess buying or selling
interest that occurs at certain price
levels right this imbalances suggests
that there's a large number of traders
who have taken positions around these
levels and then once the market starts
reversing
okay because what You' have here is
you'd have aggressive buying um and
strong buying interest up here near the
24 25 area and once these Traders can't
move the market higher essentially
they're trapped right and the market
starts drifting down because now what
you've done is you've had aggressive
buyers come in right help move the
market up but they're still buying but
once that once they sort of run out of
bullets right and and you know it's sort
of a combination of thing one is sort of
running out of buying interest right
they run out of buying power and two
sometimes it's a bit of fomo right
everyone sees oh we're coming back up to
this uh double top we're going to break
out and go higher up to 117 even right
so everyone's rushing in once they've
rushed in and they've bought you sort of
have no more buying interest right and
what's going to happen is the natural
order of the World selling interest is
going to come in and it's going to move
it lower because everyone that came in
buying helped move move the market
higher they're done okay so you don't
have that aggressive buying necessarily
in the market to help move the market
higher and if you're looking at a bar
chart you can't tell
that okay and I know some people I see
people post things oh you have uh trap
Traders down here trap Traders up here
anytime there's a big wick say oh
there's trap Traders and that's just
kind of BS um but if you're looking at
the order flow there are signs that you
can look
for that make it a lot clearer right so
why wouldn't you use the tools that help
you to understand the
market better okay and that's why I
created the orderflows trader software
is for my own use okay then you know
over time people sought and like hey can
I get a copy that that's how the order
fors Trader um you know went on from
there because you know I was using a
footprint for my own trading a different
uh person's footprint and you I sat down
I said you know hey can I can I take you
know my concept of how I look for trap
Traders in the market can I put it into
a footprint so it's going to highlight
it to me okay and we don't call it trap
Traders we actually call it uh imbalance
reversals okay because remember right
what you're looking for is excess buying
or selling interest that occurs around
certain levels right and it's often seen
through
imbalances okay so let's uh just take a
look at it here it's a simple tool okay
call it imbalance reversal right here
I was going to enable it add it to my
chart and I can see right here I've got
an imbalance reversal which is
indicative of um trap Traders and the
market sold off that's this uh you know
this is a double top but it's coming in
actually on this bar right after the
double top right it's coming in in this
bar right here being able to identify
easily and quickly where there's trap
Traders you know it makes life a lot
easier as a Trader
right you don't have to sit here and
sort of Wonder oh is that trap Traders
or not here let me just make one little
adjustment here on the Candlestick
width just to expand the
candle and again let me just remove it
and I'll sort of take you through what's
taking place here on the on the
footprint where is it I imbalance
reversal okay
disable
you can see here right this is it right
you can see this buying and balance 1056
even got a nice selling and balance 1869
so what happened right Market came back
up to this double top at 25 starts
coming down trades down to 19 starts
coming up right you got a strong
aggressive buying here 253 versus 1056
that's a buying balance right I I use 4
to one
400% you even got a strong bid here 1869
so you know buyers are coming into this
Market
um both aggressively right lifting this
offer here leaving a nice buying
imbalance and passively right leaving
this nice selling imbalance here right
because what happened Market gets up to
24 strong selling comes in right it's 23
24 nice big siiz bid here that's getting
sold into and the market drops okay and
just keeps dropping right gets down to
03 here but essentially you know 05 06
07 is
is good enough and again
it's can be easily identified in the
order flow this is actually one of the
original tools that I had in the order
flows Trader you know almost 10 years
ago and you know even today it's still
very valid okay so let's just take a
look this is a bond four range chart
here's one right here this is 742 again
we had the CPI this morning okay and
just to refresh your memory on what
happened in the market on the
CPI this happened okay so honestly
you're not going to be trading during
that time or you know 15 20 you know a
half hour afterwards once the market
settles down um but there was a little
imbalance reversal here at 742 Market
did sell off a little bit again I'm not
going to say there was one here but
there was again
732 you're not going to buy it takes a
lot of honestly to buy right after the
market drops from 118 down to 116 two
full uh
handles to try and pick a low but again
there was a sign here of trap Traders
but let's go back to again this is when
the number came out at 7:30 let's go
back to the previous day okay well this
was at night this was 2: in the morning
here this was at
9:30 did the market go down not much I
mean honestly trading bonds head of
CPI at 9:30 p.m. is a snoozefest um even
here 2: in the morning again I I I I'm a
little surprised the market did get this
rally but let's take a look at the
previous day okay so 3 in the morning
here imbalance reversal trap Traders
coming in right here people
think that trap
Traders right let just go back to chart
I like to look at on bonds is is a four
range chart people automatically think
that Traders have to be trapped at highs
or
lows okay they don't right Traders can
be trapped right here they can be
trapped right here they can be trapped
almost anywhere basically these people
that are in a position and the market is
moving significantly against those guys
okay that's what trapped means it's
traders that are holding losing
position um you know sometimes people
reason people think that oh there's trap
Traders down here that caused this
Market to Rally no it doesn't because
you know probably the volume that traded
down here is just a couple hundred
contracts right each of these bars trade
thousands so you know if
there's 900 or a, traders that sold down
here into the low they got to cover it
it's not going to cause this big massive
rally because there's in bonds and most
markets there's healthy volume there's
you know this bar trades probably 5,000
the next bar 7,000 the next bar 6,000
you know
it those Trad traders that sold a
thousand down here at the low there's
plenty of liquidity to get out right not
me squeeze that there's no liquidity
there's plenty of liquidity in these in
these markets and
um you know but people think that oh the
Traders are trapped here and that causes
big Market rally no it it doesn't I mean
just look at the liquidity of a market
um you know here's the depth of
Market in the bonds right now every bid
price got over every offer price
basically got over a th000 this one's
got 900 and there's probably some
icebergs stick hidden in there as well
so there is plenty of liquidity so you
say person sold 5,000 down here at the
low they could get out to go move it
maybe three four ticks but they could
get out it's not going to cause this
massive rally and this just sort of one
of the things that that that irks me
when I see all there's trap Traders up
here and caus this big Market to sell
off well there's plenty of exit
liquidity um so but
basically look for imbalances around the
price levels where Traders can be
potentially trapped okay so being able
to identify these levels right here here
okay I mean you got not a huge move but
I mean you know once you re identify
this in real time one tick two ticks
three ticks four ticks five ticks four
or five ticks in the bonds I know some
guys that trade Bonds in 10 right it's
you know bonds is 3125 a
tick they're just trying to get three
ticks out of the market thing is though
that they're trading you know 10 15 20
contracts at a time so three ticks I
mean my calculator do the math right
three ticks and 3125 is like 93 bucks
and you trading 10 contracts that's 900
bucks but anyway again I'm not uh
advocating that but I'm just telling you
that's how some Traders approach the
market right and you just it's
identifiable in the footprint over and
over and it's it's just very useful if
you have a tool all right like the
orderflows trader that can help you
identify it right that's why I created
the orderflows traders to help me see
this because you know honestly if I'm
looking at a plain footprint chart okay
and this is just a plain vanilla
footprint chart bid ask point of control
all right I've got a lot of tools in
here
and you know you can see I got
exhaustion prints imbalance reload
Etc there's a lot of things I like to
look for okay and sometimes I can get
lost in it and miss it right that's why
I created the orderflows trader is to
help Traders be able to identify things
very quickly right that
was imbalance reversal right down here
but something as simple as Maybe an
exhaustion print okay which is very
little volume it's sort of the opposite
of um imbalanced reversal which is a lot
of volume and if I could quickly
identify oh hey there's lack of volume
up here lack of volume up here lack of
volume right I can catch some decent
moves okay now you know I do teach you
guys how to identify this how to look
for them I do have a series of videos um
inside the orderflows trader sort of
members area that can help you see
things that you probably don't
know are taking place in the market
right it's not all about heavy volume
sometimes it's about light volume but
anyway I digress I'm going to end this
video there before I start really going
off on a tangent so again you know if
you like my videos be sure to hit the
Subscribe button and I'll see you guys
on the next video
bye-bye